bien mes chers collègues la séance est
reprise merci de vous
installer
merci
beaucoup mes chers collègues nous
recevons ce matin dans le cadre d'une
audition commune consacrée aux
perspectives économiques de la France et
leurs conséquences pour nos finances
publiques Monsieur Patrick Arthus
conseiller économique chez Naxis
monsieur Erric eer directeur du
département analyse et prévision de
l'OFCE et Madame Sandrine duchenen
directrice des risques de la conformité
du contrôle permanent de Crédit Mutuel
alliance
fédérale cette audition s'inscrit dans
le cadre des travaux de notre commission
relatif à l'examen du projet de loi de
finances pour 2024 et dans un moment où
nous venons de reconstituer la
commission avec un certain nombre de
nouveaux membres de cette commission
nous para utile de faire un point un peu
macroéconomique ce projet de loi de
finances pour 2024 est en effet
construit sur ensemble d'hypothèses
macro-économiques formulées par le
gouvernement et sur lesquelles notre
commission souhaite bénéficier de vos
analyses après avoir entendu le 27
septembre dernier Monsieur Pierre
moscovissi en sa qualité de président du
Haut Conseil des finances
publicque en titre de
préambule je me limiterai à rappeler que
le gouvernement prévoit une croissance
du PIB de 1,4 % en 2024
cela constitue à ce jour une hypothèse
haute si l'on s'en tient au consensus
des économistes et qui logiquement avec
une inflation estimée à 2,6 % se
retrouve dans des prévisions de recettes
qui s'en trouent également
rehaussé nous aimerions connaître
évidemment votre sentiment sur le
sujet alors que la Banque centrale
européenne a procédé à un nouveau
resserrement des conditions de crédit en
septembre dernier les prévisions
macro-économiques pour 2024 paraissent
ainsi plutôt optimistes l'inflation
diminurée la consommation des ménage
repartirait à la hausse l'investissement
des entreprises ne serait que peu
affecté par une politique monétaire
pourtant très restrictive après une
année de baisse l'emploi augmenterait et
le chômage diminuerait encore euh que
pouvez-vous nous dire vous voyez que
j'ai pas porté moi-même de jugement ou
ou mis d'adjectifs que pouvez-vous nous
dire de ces hypothèses nous nous
interrogeons également sur les
conséquences économiques que pourrait
avoir tant le renchérissement du pétrole
à l'œuvre depuis cet été que les
tensions géopolitiques c'est sans doute
plus complexe au Moyen-Orient depuis
début octobre sans plus attendre donc je
cède la parole à Madame Sandrine duchè
puis à Monsieur Patrick arartus et enfin
à
Eric pour un propos liminaire d'environ
10 minutes chacun s'ils le veulent bien
et nous passerons ensuite aux questions
des commissaires Sandrine duchen oui
merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs
euh comme vous le savez je suis depuis
quelques mois membres du Haut Conseil
des finances publiques donc je me
propose déjà de vous décrypter la teneur
des réflexions et des travaux du Haut
Conseil he qui ont été sous-jacents à
l'avis sur le projet de boie de finance
et euh le projet de laalpfp la loi la
loi pluriannuelle finances publiques
programmation pluriannuelle des finances
publiques
pardonnez-moi en méthode même processus
que d'habitude he nous avons auditionné
les ministères nous avons
auditionné quelques instituts
indépendants nous avons sollicité des
réponses écrites par l'envoi de de
questionnaires au ministère nous avons
obtenu des réponses et nous sommes
forgés un avis donc euh l'appréciation
hein sur la prévision de croissance pour
2024 et de façon consensuelle elle est
euh le constat d'un écart que l'on peut
qualifier de significatif euh par
rapport au consensus hein un demi-point
ce n'est pas rien euh alors on pourra
objecter que c'était la exactement la
même configuration l'année dernière hein
puisque le le Haut Conseil avait aussi
alerté sur le caractère optimiste de la
prévision de croissance qui finalement
se révèle être proche de ce qui avait
été prévu par le gouvernement cette
année euh en faisant ça je pense qu'on
se tromperait sur l'objet et la fonction
du haut-ceil des finances publiques
puisque le haut-coneil ne fait pas de
prévision de croissance en propre il ne
parie pas sur la croissance l'année
prochaine son rôle c'est de constater
les des cas à un moment donné au
consensus et de qualifier de cette façon
la prévision de croissance qui est et de
finances publiqu qui est affiché par le
gouvernement donc c'est bien dans cette
perspective qu'il faut s'inscrire et
c'est ce que nous avons fait cette année
dans un contexte d'incertitude qui est
forte je pense que mes collègues y
reviendront tout ça pour constater sur
la prévision de croissance que quand on
regarde l' ensemble des postes de la
demande mais tous les postes
s'inscrivent dans les fourchettes hautes
des prévisions des autres instituts la
résultante faisant un écart significatif
et donc je pense que pour
vous le le point saillant c'est quand
même ce biais optimiste qui peut exister
apparaître d'année en année dans les
prévisions de croissance avec leurs
impacts induits sur les finances
publiques donc c'est déjà ce point-là
sur lequel je voudrais attirer votre
attention biais optimiste systématique
ou non c'est vraiment une question
aujourd'hui pour les prévisions qui sont
sous-jacentes aux lois de finances dans
le détail he sur le le projet de loi de
finance le le Haut Conseil a pointé un
certain nombre d'éléments sur le
déficit la prévision de recette qui
comme vous l'avez dit monsieur le
Président découle de l' enchaî des
enchaînements macro-économiques qui sont
sous-jacents à la prévision de
croissance donc une croissance plus
élevée et également un contenu en emploi
taxable de la croissance qui est aussi
assez riche donc tout ça fait une
prévision de recette que l'on peut
considérer comme étant dans le haut de
la fourchette sur la dépense le Haut
Conseil a pointé à relever hein le les
effets de de suppression des mesures de
soutien en matière énerg étique pour
relever
également au-delà de ces économies qui
sont bel et bien inscrites dans le
projet doit de finance il y a peu
d'économie structurelle
documenté dans la trajectoire de
finances publiqu en 2024 et même au-delà
et en résultant de tout ça le Haut
Conseil relève la fragilité de la
trajectoire de desésendettement affiché
à partir de de 2024 et relève qu'en 2023
la baisse du du ratio dett sur PIB est
quand même beaucoup imputable au
surgissement de l'inflation donc voilà
le paysage euh que l'on peut dessiner
alors euh moi en guise de voilà de pour
pour lancer le débat
euh et je dirais que à court terme quand
même pour 2024 euh on voit peu
d'éléments d'accélération
macro-économique aujourd'hui euh en
France en Europe et même dans le monde
donc qu'est-ce qui pourrait y avoir
comme facteur d'accélération de la
croissance bon la croissance mondiale et
le commerce mondial la croissance
mondiale elle est affectée aujourd'hui
par le fort ralentissement en Chine plus
près de nous nous avons nos voisins qui
sont quand même très dépendants du
commerce international l'Allemagne et
l'Italie qui sont eux-mêmes affectés par
le ralentissement chinois et donc
paricochet il est rare quand même que la
croissance française soit très découplée
de la croissance allemande et italienne
donc il y a pas à mon avis
hein mes collègues mais il y a peu de
facteur d'accélération côté commerce et
demande adressé à la France demande
externe
de le pétrole alors on a beaucoup
discuté
beaucoup spéculé he sur le les cours du
pétrole bon tout ça est fragile mais
aujourd'hui il y a pas de tendance baiss
sur le prix du pétrole il y a même
plutôt un regain d'incertitude et un
regain sur les prix de l'énergie et il y
a quand même aussi de façon sous-jacente
un contexte inflationniste qui reste
assez persistant donc ça c'est le deème
point 3ème point la politique monétaire
qui est là un vrai sujet de discussion
hein euh on est face à un choc
historique de remonter des taux
d'intérêts 450 points de base en 18 mois
c'est absolument inédit depuis 40 ans
donc il y a derrière la question des
effets de ce choc monétaire sur
l'investissement et on voit déjà en tout
cas sur le marché immobilier les effets
de ralentis de ralentissement et même de
freinage très important induit par la
hausse des taux d'intérêt donc pour vous
le point d'attention c'est quel impact
de la hausse des taux et est-ce qu'on a
bien engranger tous les effets on y
viendra les uns et les autres par la
suite 4 point l'ajustement des finances
publiques alors on peut discuter hein de
ce qu'il y a en terme d'économie dans
dans le PLF mais en tout cas il y a
quand même une orientation qui est très
clairement
donnée à la réduction du déficit et à
l'amélioration du déficit structurel
donc à notre avis au Conseil pas
d'impulsion positive sur la croissance à
attendre l'année prochaine et enfin j'en
ai parlé le choc immobilier qui est un
élément en soi qui pèse sur la sur la
croissance et et on sait bien que dans
on a des des précédents historiques de
crise immobilière qui sont quand même
souvent assez durables donc voilà pour
toutes ces raisons moi je vois pas
tellement
d'ingrédient pour une accélération
immédiate de la croissance en Europe et
en France et dans ce contexte si on
regarde les prévisions et c'est le cas
de la prévision du gouvernement mais
c'est le cas d'autres instituts le fact
d'accélération que l'on voit c'est le
pouvoir d'achat le pouvoir d'achat qui
vient de du reflux de l'inflation sous
l'impact de la politique monétaire donc
avec des degrés divers mais c'est le
facteur d'accélération qui est endogène
inscrit dans les comptes donc ça c'est
le premier premier élément de cadrage
mais au-delà de ces effets mécaniques
moi je dirais qu'il y a TR enjeux fort
et là on est dans une forme
d'incertitude radicale sur les
comportements donc il y a pour moi
trois mystères qu'on essaie de lever
mais qui aujourd'hui restent posé et ça
c'est très important aussi pour la
trajectoire de croissance à venir le
premier mystère c'est
l'emploi il y a eu depuis le covid un
surplomb d'emploi très important en
France un ralentissement de la
productivité qui est même plus important
que ce que l'on observe dans les autres
pays européens alors tu y reviendras
sans doute parce que vous avez fait des
décompositions très propres donc il y a
une partie qui s'explique de façon très
précise puis il y a une partie qui
s'explique pas donc le sujet c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on fait en prévision de la
partie qui ne s'explique pas et c'est
toujours les deux deux phases d'une même
pièce c'est-à-dire que plus on met
d'emploi plus on a de la croissance à
court terme et des facteurs de
croissance mais
aussi plus il y a sans doute des effets
de long terme sur la productivité donc
la croissance potentielle donc on peut
jamais gagner sur les deux tableaux et
la question est voilà que fait-on de ce
dilemme et c'est ça fait partie des
question qu'on a posé au ministère
deuxièmement l'épargne autre
mystère il y a eu aussi en France mais
comme dans tous les autres pays un
surplomb d'épargne très important
pendant la crise covid qu'on a bien
documenté qui s'explique ce qui
s'explique moins c'est pourquoi est-ce
que l'épargne en France reste à un
niveau très élevé encore aujourd'hui
alors que par exemple les consommateurs
américains ont déjà dépensé leur surplu
accumulé pendant la crise covid donc
c'est un point et c'est un point aussi
pour 2024 parce que nombre de
déterminant ne vont pas dans le sens
d'une baisse de l'épargne en
2024 l'accélération du revenu réel c'est
plôt une hausse de
l'épargne le refus de
l'inflation le ça va plutôt dans l'autre
sens mais le le chômage et l'emploi
favoriseent plutôt des comportements de
précaution et puis on a globalement un
contexte d'incertitude peut-être
d'incertitude sur l'avenir avec la
réforme des retraites enfin il y a un
contexte qui à mon avis n'est pas
propice à une baisse du taux d'épargne
expliqué par des comportements habituels
donc il faut faire des parties prix et
chacun en fait et ce n'est pas un
problème ce qu'il faut faire à mon avis
c'est VI
expliciter les
choix de modélisation ou les choix de
comportement qui sont fait et il y en a
dans les autres prévisions mais il faut
vraiment interroger ce
pointlà ce qui ce qui relève du jugement
pur et puis troisième point c'est
l'investissement autre mystère c'est on
a toujours Patrick dira peut-être le
contraire mais on a toujours un taux
d'investissement qui reste élevé en brut
en France malgré la hausse des taux et
c'est c'est vrai que côté banque pour ce
que j'en observe on a toujours on n pas
eu d'effondrement des crédits à
l'investissement donc tout ça colle dans
le sens d'une forme de d'inexplicabilité
aussi du comportement
d'investissement aujourd'hui donc enfin
moi personnellement je pense que ça peut
pas continuer et que les effets du choc
vont venir
donc il faut que ce soit inscrit dans
les prévision c'est la même chose sur
l'investissement logement je pense qu'on
est on est pas au bout de des effets
pleins du choc de tout voilà pour donner
le le un peu les éléments de contexte et
envoyer le et lancer le débat vis-à-vis
de mes voisins et moi je pense que dans
ce contexte ce qui compte
c'est la transparence la documentation
des choix euh pour qu'on puisse
pleinement se forger une opinion sur le
caractère plus ou optimiste des
prévisions voilà pour mon propos
liininaire monsieur le Président merci
Madame duchè donc on va demander à
Patrick arartus de lever finalement tous
ces
mystères tout ça est très mystérieux ça
va devenir
lumineux il faut appuyer sur
le appuyer sur le
m
voilà merci monsieur le Président
bonjour mesdames et messieurs donc je
vais je je vais pas répéter ce qu'a dit
très bien Sandrine je vais je je vais je
vais me demander ce qui ce ce ce qui
doit être l'objet de réflexion lorsqu'on
fait une prévision économique à
l'horizon 2024 2025 et et quels sont les
les les points sur laquel sur le sur
lesquels il y a l'essentiel de
l'incertitude alors le je crois que le
premier point sur lequel sur lequel il
faut réfléchir c'est c'est la
productivité c'est les gains de
productivité je vais essayer de vous
montrer des
productivité ou alors mais c'est des
années lumière
donc je
vais je vais vous montrer les gains de
productivité donc passer ple de slid
mais voilà alors j'ai pas l'Europe je
j'ai pas la France je vais commenter la
France mais vous voyez que il y a il y a
un écart croissant alors c'est le niveau
de la productivité du travail he c'est
la la valeur ajoutée par salarié et vous
voyez qu'aux États-Unis alors 2000 2020-
2021 c'est très perturbé par la la
manière dont les pays ont réagi à la
crise du du covid aux États-Unis il y a
des licenciements en Europe il y a du
chômage partiel indemnisé par l'État il
faut regarder la tendance voyez la
productivité du travail en Europe elle
est légèrement est croissante par
rapport au son niveau de
2018-29 aux États-Unis elle reste sur
une tendance de croissance de à peu près
1,5 % par an donc il y a une anomalie
européenne à partir de 2018 et cette
anomalie européenne elle est
particulièrement forte en France parce
que si vous comparez le niveau de
productivité du travail aujourd'hui au
niveau de productivité du travail au 2e
trimestre 2018 ce qui est le le le pic
de la productivité en France on a une
baisse de 6 % du niveau de productivité
du travail
et ça c'est absolument abominable parce
que ça interdit d'augmenter les salaires
réels ça fait ça fait subir à l'état des
pertes de recettes fiscales et et et
donc il faut absolument comprendre pour
savoir si on doit adhérer à la thèse du
gouvernement ou de la BCE qui a un
retour de gain de productivité assez
fort en 2000 en 2024 2025 la BCE est
encore au-dessus du gouvernement Fran
fra ou bien si on va continuer à avir
une stagnation de la productivité alors
si si on compare un scénario de
stagnation de la productivité un
scénario de de retour à la tendance de
la productivité antérieure à partir de
2024 dans le scénario de stagnation de
la productivité il y a 4 points de PIB
en moins en 2027 c'està-dire de points
de déficit public en plus c'estàdire que
le déficit public serait de pas de 2,8%
mais de 4,8 % en 2027 donc c'est c'est
une question absolument cruciale de de
savoir ce qu'on dit sur la productivité
sachant que le gouvernement français ou
la BCE on ont fait l'hypothèse queil y
aurait un redémarrage assez rapide de
des gains de productivité
alors alors che eric veut enarler aussi
mais quel quel qu quelles sont les
explications du ralentissement de la
productivité bon pour moi il y a la
baisse du chômage et comme Sandrine
vient de le dire on peut pas avoir à la
fois le retour sur le marché du travail
de salariés peu qualifiés et des gains
de productivité rapide donc il faut
choisir et on
a comme comme le taux de chômage
qualifié est en dessous de 4 % en France
et qu'il est très peu cyclique et donc
quand vous avez une baisse du chômage
vous avez une baisse essentiellement du
chômage des peu qualifiés qui fait
reculer la productivité globale de de la
la de la population active donc prière
explication deè iation c'est
l'apprentissage il y a des estimations
qui disent que à peu près entre le quart
et le tiers de la perte de gain de
productivité et D et dû à
l'apprentissage mais ça c'est une bonne
nouvelle parce que les apprentis sont
peu productifs au début et ils viendront
plus productifs plus tard et la trisème
explication c'est l'absentéisme il y a
il y a un taux d'absentéisme dans les
entreprises en France qui a monté de 2
points et demi entre 2018 et aujourd'hui
et qui fait baisser la durée effective
du travail et qui fait baisser la produc
production des entreprises on a un taux
d'absentéisme qui est de 6,5 % dans les
entreprises françaises il estit 3 % de 3
et5 % il y a y a il y a moins de 10 ans
et c'est un absentéisme essentiellement
des jeunes de 20 à 35 ans et les les les
vieux comme moi travaillent un peu plus
prennent moins cons maladie mais les
jeunes on prennent beaucoup et et ça
c'est un problème c'est c'est un
problème qui a
relié au au fait qu'il y a beaucoup de
jeunes qui disent qu'il y a pas de sens
à leur travail enfin il y a des enquêtes
de sociologues qui montrent qu'il y a
une perte de sens du travail une perte
de d'implication dans le travail assez
fort dans les jeunes alors ma ma vision
c'est que ces causes du recul de la
productivité sont structurelles
l'absentéisme le le le taux de chômage
faible des non qualifiés et puis le
l'apprentissage mais l'apprentissage ça
mettra beaucoup d'années avoir des
effets positifs et donc que les
hypothèses du gouvernement sur 2024 2025
et même jusqu'en 2027 sont très très
très très optimistes sur les gains de
productivité et moi je pense que ça sera
très difficile de faire repartir la
productivité à cet horizon et donc je
pense que il y a une surestimation
peut-être pas de deux peut-être pas de
quatre points mais au moins de trois
points du niveau de PIB en 2027 par les
prévisions officielles donc ça c'est la
la première question euh la seconde
question euh sur les finances publiques
c'est la question des taux d'intérêt
réel alors là heureusement
ah oui alors je voulais je voulais quand
même vous montrer ça alors j'ai montré
j'ai la zone euro mais c'est la France
faut comprendre qu'on a je vais je vais
parler de l'inflation des taux d'intérêt
réel qui sont mes deux derniers points
on a un changement de régime incroyable
en économie vous avez une enquête qui
est très intéressante et qui donne à peu
près les mêmes résultats en France sur
les facteurs qui limitent la production
donc j'ai je vous ai montré les services
parce que c'est plus gros que
l'industrie mais les résultats de
l'industrie sont à peu près les mêmes
alors concentrez-vous vous sur trois
facteurs qui limitent la production donc
la ligne bleue c'est l'insuffisance de
la demande et vous voyez que je et alors
quand quand vous quand le le facteur est
en dessous de zéro il pèse pas il pèse
pas comme facteur explicatif donc vous
voyez jusque que jusqu'en 2016 17 le
facteur essentiel de limitation de la
production c'était l'insuffisance de la
demande les entreprises disaientah si on
avait plus de demande on pourrait
produire plus bon voilà c'est un régime
kenésien normal et cetera et à partir de
2017 vous vous vous à part 2000 2020
enfin la covid il y avait pas de demande
mais si vous excluez 2020 il y a plus du
tout d'entreprises qui mentionnent
l'insuffisance de la demande les
entreprises mentionnent deux facteurs de
de de limitation de la production c'est
les difficultés d'embauche et
l'insuffisance des équipements donc il y
a pas assez de capital matériel dans les
entreprises et donc ça ça veut dire que
on est en on est dans un
régime a il y a pas assez d'offrees il y
a il y a pas on est passé d'un régime de
d'insuffisance de la demande à un régime
d'excès de demande il y a trop de
demande par rapport à l'offre puisqu'il
manque il manque du travail et il manque
des équipements dans les entreprises
alors ça ça me donne l'occasion de de de
de discuter le le niveau
d'investissement des entreprises
françaises alors c'est c'est une
discussion très compliquée en raison de
problème statistiqu absolument
abominable qui qui qui qui qui affecte
l'investissement au logiciel des
entreprise si vous regardez le taux
d'investissement net des entreprises
euh
françaises vous avez un une baisse à
partir de 2008 et on ne retrouve pas
aujourd'hui le niveau de 2008 et net ça
veut dire net de l'amortissement du du
capital hein et et ça correspond au fait
que le capital des entreprises augmente
peu ce qui déprime la croissance mais si
vous regardez le taux d'investissement
brut total des entreprises vous avez les
entreprises françaises sont très
au-dessus de l'ensemble des entreprises
européennes et ça c'est dû à un niveau
extraordinairement élevé en France de
l'investissement logiciel et qui est
amorti ce qui explique que vous avez une
hausse parallèle des amortissements et
de l'investissement logiciel je enfin
des discussions que j'ai eu avec le
directeur général de l'INC sur ce point
il apparaît que la France ne
comptabilise pas de la même manière que
les autres pays l'investissement en
logiciel et donc je je je pense que il
faut pas
avoir l'illusion que les entreprises
françaises investissent beaucoup si vous
enlevez l'investissement en logiciel les
entreprises françaises investissent sur
le total le total de de ces leurs autres
investissements moins que les
entreprises de la zone euro et beaucoup
moins que les entrepris américaines donc
je pense qu'il y a un problème
statistique concernant l'investissement
logiciel apparemment
le un point technique ce problème log
statistique vient de ce que la l'INC
compte comme investissement en logiciels
des entreprises les logiciels développés
dans l'entreprise et que les autres
instituts de statistiques ne compent que
les logiciels achetés par l'entreprise
et et ça fait ça fait deux points de PIP
d'écart sur le taux d'investissement
donc c'est c'est donc voilà donc je
pense que il y a une insuffisance qui
est confirmé par cette enquête de de de
d'équipement dans les entreprises
françaises on na pas investi assez
depuis 2017 et donc et donc c'est c'est
c'est c'est une cause apparition de ce
régime d'excès de demande qui est qui
est clairement inflationniste si vous
avez trop de demande par rapport à
l'offre ben les entreprises sont se
monte leur prix alors ça ça me ça me ça
me tire sur mes deux derniers points qui
est qui sont la perspective d'inflation
et la perspective de la perspective pour
les taux d'intérêt réel alors
l'inflation il faut évidemment regarder
la zone euro et je vais je vais je vais
juste vous montrer la la grande diff
différence qui existe entre l'inflation
aux États-Unis et l'inflation dans la
zone euro et donc je retrouve alors oui
faut que je faut que je faut que je
remonte pédestrement malheureusement
peut-être j'ai oublié l'inflation aux
États-Unis parce que l'inflation aux
États-Unis si vous si vous enlevez au
États-Unis il y a une bizarrerie aussi
statistique que les l'inflation inclut
les loyers imputés au propriétair de
logement ce qui ne correspond à rien ce
qui correspond et donc si vous enlevez
ces loyers imputés inflation aux
États-Unis et en septembre de de cette
année de 2,2 %. et si vous avez si vous
enlevez la totalité des loyers elle est
de 1,9 % donc les États-Unis ont une
inflation qui est revenue à la normale
et donc si vous faites le même calcul
dans la zone euro alors ça je peux vous
le montrer euh
alors hop je suis allé trop loin voilà
si vous faites le même calcul de la dans
la zone euro vous voyez que l'inflation
horors énergie alimenta tion et est à
6,5 % en septembre de cette année donc
plus de trois points plus élevés que que
l'inflation américaine et ça c'est c'est
le résultat de c'est le résultat de ce
que ce que j'ai dit jusqu'à présent
un il y a pas de gain de productivité
donc même quand vous avez zéro de
croissance vous créez des emplois et
vous faites baisser le chômage et donc
vous ne guérissez jamais la tension
forte du marché du travail si vous
regardez les difficultés d'embauche dans
la zone euro elles sont au plus haut les
difficultés d'embauche aux États-Unis
sont en dessous de leur niveau
tendantiel et puis
deuxièmement
le donc la la la l'absence de
productivité et puis deuxièmement la
situation d'excès de demande donc il y a
trop de demande et donc les entreprises
sont incitées à continuer à monter leur
marge bénéficiaire pour investir
davantage et ça explique peut-être que
l'investissement réagit peu à la
conjoncture parce que les entreprises
savent qu'elles doivent investir pour
satisfaire la demande donc je pense que
l'inflation de la zone euro sera
beaucoup plus élevé que ce que la
BCE prévoit et que l'inflation française
sera plus élevée que ce que le
gouvernement français prévoit l'un et
l'autre prévoi un retour à 2 %
d'inflation à la fin de 2025 et je pense
qu'ils sont optimistes d'au moins un
point et probablement un peu plus et et
d'ailleurs si vous
regardez l'inflation anticipée à 10 ans
dans la zone euro elle est 2,7 %. et
donc la la crédibilité de la BCE est
entamée hein par ce par C ces
hésitations dans la lutte contre
l'inflation ce qui fait que il est très
très improbable qu'on retrouve 2 %
d'inflation c'est c'est impossible même
qu'on retrouve 2 % eninflation à la fin
de 2025 on sera plutôt autour de 3 %
peut-être voilà alors mon dernier point
concernant les finances publiques c'est
euh c'est la question des des taux
d'intérêt réel et alors les taux
d'intérêt réel alors ils sont ils sont
hop alors je je descends faut que je
descende regardez
pas voilà non l' et ca alors voilà j'y
arrive voilà les taux les taux d'intérêt
réel ce qui ce qui compte pour le pour
l'évolution de la tête publique c'est
pas les taux d'intérêt c'est les
dominaux c'est les taux d'intérêt réel
donc je calcule ici les taux d'intérêt
réel en en soustrayant du taux d'intérêt
nominal à 10 ans le swap d'inflation à
ans le côté sympathique du CH c'est les
de don de la zone euro sont exactement
les mêmes que les données de la France
par par miracle le taux d'intérêt moyen
de la zone euro c'est le taux d'intérêt
de la France donc vous êtes j'ai pas
regardé ce matin vous êtes à 3,7 % à peu
près en ce moment et vous voyez que là
il y a eu un mouvement de baisse très
forte des taux d'intérêt réel les taux
d'intérêt réel depuis 2015 sont très
inférieurs sont négatifs et sont très
inférieurs à la croissance de la zone
euro et dans dans cette configuration
vous pouvez faire faire ce que vous
voulez avec les déficits publics c'est
le fait que les taux d'intérêt réel sont
inférieurs à la croissance qui
remboursera la tête publique aujourd'hui
les taux d'intérêt réel de la zone euro
sont un peu au-dessus de 1 % et donc
c'est à peu près le niveau de la
croissance potentielle de la zone euro
qu'est-ce que ça nous dit sur le besoin
de consolidation des finances publiques
B on a en France un déficit primaire
c'est hors intérêt sur la dette qui est
qui est qui est de 3 % du PIB cette
année qui sera qui sera probablement
c'est si les prévisions budgétaires du
gouvernement sont sont justes qui sera
probablement plus plus près de 2,2 2,3 %
du PIB l'année prochaine pour rendre
l'État français solvable il faut faire
disparaître le déficit primaire donc le
besoin de réduction du déficit public
cette année ce serait trois points de
PIB pour pour stabiliser le taux
d'endettement public parce que à partir
de de maintenant le l'inflation ne fera
pu baisser le taux d'endettement public
on aura un taux d'endettement public qui
sera stable si il n'y a plus de déficit
primaire donc on a trois points de
déficit public en trop par rapport à ce
qui stabiliserait le et et et je fais
une hypothèse de croissance de long
terme de la France de 1 % qui correspond
à mon hypothèse c'est c'est en dessous
du 16 du gouvernement mais ça ça ça
correspond à mon hypothèse sur les gains
de productivité donc voilà je m'arrête
là donc les les points les points les
plus importants c'est le débat sur la
productivité ce qui cause la lenteur de
dégâ de productivité le le débat sur
l'inflation et la remontée très forte
des taux d'intérêt réel qui va affecter
beaucoup le le le besoin de de
consolidation
budgétaire merci Monsieur Artus nous
poursuivons avec Éric Heyer merci
monsieur le Président bonjour à tous
donc alors je vais aller à SZ ville
parce que je partage un grand nombre de
de points alors peut-être que je il y a
quatre messages que j'aimerais vous
faire passer alors une précision mais
j'imagine que mes collègues ont la même
c'estàdire que tout ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui c'est avant les événements
du 7 octobre et donc on n'intègre pas
aujourd'hui dans nos
prévisions une des conséquences de de de
ce qui s'est passé le le 7 octobre donc
ensuite le le premier message alors sur
l'activité le message principal c'est
que on n'est pas il y a pas de récession
à l'horizon de prévision
dans dans dans les pays dans dans tous
les pays que l'on que l'on observe à
l'exception de l'Allemagne et que ce
queon ce qui est à l'œuvre c'est un
ralentissement qui a accéléré d'accord
donc on voyait tout c'est un
ralentissement il est un peu plus rapide
que ce que l'on ce que l'on anticipait
pour un certain nombre de de facteurs
communs mais allez on on on on va y
venir tout à l'heure sur la politique
monétaire les tensions sur le marché
immobilier la persistance de l'inflation
mais il y a un point tout de même qui
est qui est important et surtout quand
on essaie de savoir si on a été trop
optimiste ou trop pessimiste c'est qu'il
y a des révisions de comptes aujourd'hui
on travaille quand même sur des comptes
provisoires et ce que l'on voit dans
beaucoup de pays c'est des révisions
très fortes de l'activité passée et ça
ça induit moins de croissance dans
l'avenir c'est une mauvaise n fa pour
les prévisions parce que on on
anticipait tous un rattrapage puisqu'il
n'était pas dans les comptes on disait
bah ça va venir en fait il on ça a été
intégré d'accord et donc vous voyez le
Royaume-Uni ben ils ont la révision de
des décomtes c'est quasiment deux points
de PIB il y a eu deux points de PIB
quasiment un point et demi en Espagne
plus de 1,3 c'est quand même remarquable
de voir que la France en tout cas l'INC
n'a pas revu fortement ses comptes alors
est-ce que ça veut dire que l'INC est
meilleur que les autres où est-ce que ça
veut dire que la révision des comptes va
avoir lieu plus tard et ça pourrait
expliquer une part partie des des paires
de productivité ça il faut quand même
encore le garder à l'esprit alors là
j'aurais une petite différence avec
Patrick sur ce qu'il a dit sur l'offre
et la demande que nous il nous semble
qu'au contraire
aujourd'hui le ralentissement change de
nature et que les contraintes d'offrees
sont en train petit à petit de se
résorber et que les contraintes de
demande sont en train de de se lever je
vais vous montrer alors voyez c'est ça
qui est intéressant c'est qu'avec les
mêmes enquêtes on peut dire deux choses
différentes bon donc je je vais vous le
montrer donc donc alors il y a quand
même TR TR trois slides qui vous
illustrent ce ce propos d'accord donc
d'abord le premier c'est le le bleu donc
dans tous les pays voyez que comment se
lit le bleu c'est où on en est
aujourd'hui de l'activité du PIB par
rapport à 2019 dans tous les pays
aujourd'hui on produit plus qu'en 2019
c'est pas énorme et vous voyez que bah
celui qui est le plus le
plus le moins haut par rapport à 2019
c'est l'Allemagne voy je sais pas si
vous voyez bien mais c'est le premier
point donc pour voyz c'est assez rare
que l'Allemagne soit en queue de pleton
comment se lit le rouge le rouge c'est
par rapport à ce qu'on aurait dû avoir
s'il y a pas eu de crise alors ça c'est
un peu plus théorique puis qu'il faut
avoir une projection mais voyez que
globalement personne n'a rattrapé son
niveau qu'on aurait dû avoir s'il y a
pas eu de crise donc le bleu on peut
dire il y a pas de récession dans le
monde on produit plus que avant la crise
le rouge c'est ah oui mais attention on
a quand même beaucoup perdu par rapport
à un sentier avant crise donc on appelle
ça nous une récession cachée d'accord et
donc c'est ça qui peut être et pour
répondre à Sandrine un élément de
croissance demain soit on considère que
c'est perdu à jamais soit on considère
qu'on va le rattraper petit à petit mais
c'est une réserve de croissance
potentielle et on voit qu'elle est
beaucoup plus forte en Asie que dans les
pays développés et cetera ça c'est le
premier point deuxième point et là je je
vais avoir ma petite différence avec
Patrick c'est que au contraire voyez
quand on prend les mêmes enquêtes mais
alors pays par pays et quand on regarde
quels étaient les freins d'accord alors
prenons le le le pic le rouge c'est 2022
1er trimestre c'est là où effectivement
le principal frein c'était dans tous les
pays le matériel c'estàd ok problème
d'approvisionnement et investissement et
absolument aucun problème de demande
vous voyez que la la la la barre de la
demande le rouge est très basse ce qu'on
est en train de voir avec la dernière
enquête c'est que c'est en train un peu
de se déformer d'accord et c'est déformé
vers la demande c'estàdire que petit à
petit c'est la demande qui devient un
frein un peu plus fort qu'en 2022
d'accord et que les problèmes matériels
ben sont en train de se résorber en
revanche les difficultés de recrutement
reste élevé donc le problème sur le
travail reste identique quasiment mais
le frein de sur le matériel est en train
de se lever et le frein demande qui
devient être un frein qui en tout cas
dans ces quatre grands pays B devient
même le frein le frein principal alors
où est-ce qu'on le retrouve ce frein
principal al ça c'est c'est France c'est
qu'effectivement toutes les les enquêtes
aujourd'hui que qu'ell soit sur les
entreprises ou sur les ménages sont
fortement dégradés voyez sur les
entreprises aujourd'hui le moral est au
niveau 100 qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
d'être au niveau 100 bah ça veut pas
dire une récession ou zéro croissance ça
veut dire une croissance au niveau du
potentiel allez qu'on estime entre 01 02
donc quand vous êtes à 100 bah vous
voyez vous avez une prévision à court
terme qui est de 01 02 c'est c'est à peu
près ce que DIN c'est aujourd'hui dans
sa prévision 0102 donc très peu de
croissance une croiss c'est pas la
récession mais c'est une croissance très
molle et ce qui est très déprimant c'est
le rouge c'est le moral des ménages qui
est quasiment à son plus bas voyez vous
êtes plus bas que qu'au moment de de la
période covid donc effectivement dans ce
que disait Sandrine est-ce que
globalement les ménages vont consommer
leur partie de leur éparne quand vous
avez un moral des ménag aussi faible
généralement ben c'est pas à ce
moment-là que les ménages vont puiser
dans dans dans dans laépargne et et donc
c'est ça qui va nourrir en partie les
problèmes de demande dans notre
prévisions c'està-dire que les carnets
de commande sont en train de se vider
petit à petit c'està-dire que c'est
c'était pour cela que les entreprises
avaient le moral c'est parce qu'elles
avaient des car commande qui étaient
plein à CRA elles avaient des problèmes
pour produire pas pour vendre d'accord
donc avent des carniet de commande
aujourd'hui bah les carniet de commande
sont en train de se réduire très
rapidement et ne se renouvelle pas donc
c'est ça qui nous fait dire qu'attention
les problèmes de demande sont en train
de de revenir avec le problème de
pouvoir d'achat donc je va V donc les
perspectives de croissance mais après il
y a on a une publication qui détaille un
peu plus hein mais vous voyez que
effectivement partout dans le monde on
voit un ralentissement voyez la
croissance mondiale c'est 26 23 c'est
c'est bien plus faible que ce qu'on
anticipé mais voyez il y a pas de point
négatif sauf l'Allemagne qui est en
négatif en 2023 et sinon ça fait des
croissances qui sont relativement
relativement molles le deuxième message
sur l'inflation nous nous ce qu'on
indique c'est qu'il y a une diffusion de
cette inflation d'accord mais pas de
persistance je vais essayer d'expliquer
cette nuance donc la diffusion c'est bah
on était c'est partie de l'énergie puis
ça s diffuser à l'alimentaire et c'est
en train de se diffuser dans ce qu'on
appelle le sous-jacent c'està-dire au
salaire mais les salaires ne progressent
pas comme les prix donc il y a pas
encore cette boucle prix salaire qui qui
s'enclenche et ce que l'on met dans nos
prévisions c'est que les salaires vont
rattraper le niveau des prix d'accord
mais sans boucle prix salaire pourquoi
et ça c'est la première hypothèse que
l'on fait je vais essayer de la
développer c'est parce que les
entreprises vont utiliser leur Marg pour
absorber une partie de ses salaires je
vais essayer d'expliquer comment et le
deuxième point c'est que peut-être que
c'est pas essentiel de regarder
l'inflation mais de regarder le niveau
des prix et là on voit qu'il y a des
grandes divergence Patrick a montré
qu'il y a à peu près une convergence
dans les taux d'inflation mais en terme
de niveau des prix il y aura des grandes
divergences c'est ce que je vais essayer
de montrer donc en trois graphiques donc
je vais vite donc globalement ça c'est
cette idée pour la France donc du coup
de diffusion de l'énergie de de
l'inflation énergétique vers
l'alimentaire et on voit que petit à
petit ça s'estompe et c'est l'autre
autre c'est les salaires c'est le
sous-jacent ce qui nous per ce qui nous
qui aboutit à une inflation qui devrait
diminuer d'accord et s'établir alentour
de au-dessus de 3 % donc effectivement
au-dessus du du gouvernement à l'horizon
2024 quand on regarde les taux
d'inflation on se dit il y a une sorte
de convergence voyez tous les taux
d'inflation effectivement convergent et
là je serai d'accord avec Patrick sur le
dire on n'arrivera pas à 3% au 2 %
d'inflation on va rester au-dessus y
compris en zone euro et en France je
vous l'ai montrer donc au-dessus de de
ce de de de ce 2 % à la fin 2024 et en
2025 mais ce qui est intéressant c'est
le niveau des prix c'estàdire que vous
voyez là on a l'impression que ça ça ça
converge mais les États-Unis sont partis
avant avec une inflation qui qui a
démarré avant nous et puis il y a eu des
pics donc aujourd'hui oui tout le monde
converge plus pe au prou mais quand vous
vous partez sur les niveaux des prix ben
vous voyez des grandes divergences et la
France s'en sort particulièrement bien
c'estàd queon a un niveau des prix
d'accord qui est largement en dessous du
niveau de prix que l'on peut observer y
compris aux États-Unis d'accord et bien
sûr en Allemagne au Royaume-Uni donc ça
ça peut avoir un élément sur la
compétitivité d'accord de de de
l'économie française si bien sûr les les
les les ce qui se passe sur les salaires
euh et Ben est un peu plus faible en
France ben c'est ce qu'on observe voyez
les salaires nominaux donc il y a le
bleu c'est ce qu'on observe et le jaune
c'est notre prévision bon on se trompe
hein souvent en prévision mais bon voà
allons-y tout de même bah ce qu'on
observe c'est que oui les salaires en
France où les salaires ont le moins
progressé dans les grands pays et vous
voyez le le la la le le slide d'un côté
c'est le c'est les salaires réels bon
voilà donc ça pas complètement compensé
c'estàd que il y a bien des pertes de
salaires réel partout tout donc à part
aux États-Unis d'accord ce qui peut
expliquer aussi pourquoi ils consomment
un peu plus hein d'accord mais donc il y
a bien des pertes de salaires ré dans
tous les pays mais voà le fait d'avoir
moins d'inflation on a eu moins de
salaire ah ça fait des coûts qui sont
inférieurs peut-être que au bout d'un
moment ça peut se traduire par un petit
un petit effet cice en plus dans les
années à venir et selon nos prévisions
les salaires vont quelque part rattraper
le niveau des prix mais pas complètement
puisque vous voyez que la le le point
rouge qui est le point d'arrivée est
encore en négatif mais avec des salaires
qui auront au final moins progressé en
France qu'ailleurs mais avec des paires
de salaires réel qui aur été à peu près
équivalent qu'est-ce que ça donne du
coup ben ça ça ça donne alors en terme
de de de de pouvoir d'achat ce qui là
c'est intéressant de voir que autant les
salaires réels ont été négatifs mais pas
le pouvoir d'achat donc ça veut dire
qu'il y a dans le revenu des ménages
autre chose que les salaires on le sait
mais ce qui est très étonnant dans la
période récente c'est le revenu autre
que les salaires et notamment le revenu
du capital habituellement le revenu issu
de de votre capital ça ça représente 20
% de votre revenu là aujourd'hui c'est
40 d'accord dans la progression donc ça
veut dire que ce qui a fortement
progressé dans ces derniers temps qui a
maintenu le un revenu disponible par
unité de consommation positif hein oui
alors bon ça a été négatif en 2022 mais
on le remet positif assez rapidement
c'est des des revenus autres que des
revenus des revenus salari ce qui peut
quelque part expliquer pourquoi les taux
d'épargne sont aussi élevés c'estàd qui
dispose de ces revenus issu du capital
bah c'est peut-être pas distribuer de
façon homogène dans la population
peut-être dans des salaires dans des
dans des citoyens qui ont un revenus
plus élevés or on sait que le taux
d'épargne des revenus élevés supérieur à
à ceux des revenus bas ça peut expliquer
pourquoi effectivement voyez si si vous
voulez avoir un ordre de grandeur le
taux
d'épargne avant la crise et même au
cours de la décennie avant la crise
c'est 15 % et aujourd'hui on est plutôt
à 19 % d'accord donc on est très au-delà
et on accumule voyez si vous accumulez
cette sur éparne on est à peu près à 220
230 milliards d'euros d'accord donc
c'est c'est énorme bah une partie peut
s'expliquer par un effet de composition
alors ce que l'on met en prévision c'est
qu'il y a il y aurait une très légère
baisse du taux d'éparne mais je suis
d'accord avec Sandrine c'est un peu des
paris parce que si on laisse faire une
équation standard on aurait plutôt
tendance à à à dire l'inverse mais on
sait mais on se dit qu'il y a quelqu
quelle est la bonne référence est-ce que
c'est 15 ou est-ce que c'est le 19 % on
a plutôt l'impression que c'est le 15 et
donc on dit allez ça reste élevé par
rapport au 15 mais ça fait une baisse
par rapport au au 19 donc ça ça va un
peu soutenir tout de même un un un point
important sur est-ce qu'il y a la grid
flleion voyz la grid flleion c'est
est-ce que une partie de l'inflation a
été d à un comportement de marge des
entreprises ben vous l'avez ici he en
gros voyez quand vous regardez les prix
de production ben effectivement ils
étaient très élevés en 2022 ils
commenceent à être un peu moins élevé en
inflation l'inflation baisse ça veut pas
dire que les prix baissent mais
l'inflation baisse mais quand vous
regardez la composition de pourquoi les
prix de production augmenté bah voz vous
avez soit c'est lié aux consommations
intermédiaires vous achetez plus cher
l'énergie et cetera soit c'est lié le
verre au à la rémunération de vos
salariés soit c'est lié à votre
comportement de marge soit c'est lié à
aux taxes et subvention enfin le taxe
net des subventions vous voyez que
habituellement ben c'est c'est les
consommations intermédiaire qui font
quelque part l'intégralité de de de
votre inflation de prix de production là
on voit quen sur sur les les les
derniers points connu et donc sur un an
en cumulé c'est plutôt les marges des
entreprises alors on peut dire que c'est
un effet de rattrapage d'accord en
partie mais on voit qu'il y a ça fait
maintenant 2019 2020 2022 et et 2023 où
ce sont les marches qui se restaurent
petit à petit alors ça c'est dans
l'ensemble du secteur marchand quand on
regarde dans l'industrie c'est
gigantesque d'accord dans l'industrie
c'est vraiment là où les entreprises ont
utilisé cette période pour restaurer
leur marche ça se voit où ça se voit
dans ce graphique de marge marge il se
liit assez rapidement c'estàd le niveau
de marge de 2018 et où on en est
aujourd'hui bah vous voyez que bah dans
l'énergie ils sont 18 alors pourquoi on
prend 2018 et pas 2019 comme point de
référence parce que 2019 il y a le
double cice qui fait que les marges ont
augmenté mais façon un peu artificiel
donc c'est pas un bon point de référence
on prend plutôt 2018 donc vous voyez
dans quand on regarde dans le secteur
marchand bon on est 0,8 points au-dessus
du niveau de 2018 mais c'est très ciblé
dans l'énergie et dans l'industrie ben
dans l'industrie agroalimentaire dans
les biens d'équipement c'est pas vrai
dans les services d'accord donc là il y
a effectivement un discours sectoriel à
voir et pas forcément macro-économique
le point je vais aller vite sur le le
policy mix c'est globalement sur la
politique monétaire l'idée mais ça ça a
bien été dit jeis aller vite c'est que
la hausse était très rapide on considère
que la hausse est derrière nous c'est
même on anticipe une baisse mais c'est
pas parce qu'on a anticipé une baisse en
fait en gros c'était c'est cette ligne
qui est important c'est que c'est la fin
du resserrement mais pas des effets les
effets sont retardés donc globalement ce
qu'on va avoir là en 2024 c'est les
effets à plein de la hausse des taux
passé ok sur la politique budgétaire ça
va être exactement l'inverse les effets
ne sont pas là les effets seront plutôt
après 2 2024 donc une façon de voir ces
effets là ben voyez selon nos calculs là
aussi c'est basé sur des modèles qui
sont discutable d'accord tout est on
fait pas une science exacte mais
globalement selon nous la hausse des
taux va
la croissance cette année en France de
quasiment un point et sur depuis 2022
voyez la hausse des taux aura
amputé la croissance française de même
montant que le choc inflationniste y
compris bouclier tarifaire donc en fait
c'est vraiment c double choc mais de de
de même ampleur donc oui mais 2024 c'est
vraiment les effets de la politique
monétaire qui font que globalement la
croissance va être plus basse
qu'anticipé sur la politique budgétaire
je vais vite on on on on ne on ne
qualifie pas la le budget d'austérité
d'accord dans le sens où oui la dépense
publique en point de PIB va bien baisser
en 2024 mais voyez c'est juste un retour
à un niveau d'avant-cise c'estàdire que
c'est la fin en fait de toutes les aides
c'est pas ça l'austérité l'austérité
c'est quand vous faites des des des des
baisses qui sont plus structurelles là
c'est la fin de du quoi qu'il en coûte
quelque part et et des et des aides lié
au boucliers tarifaires qui font qu'on
va revenir peu ou prou à au niveau du
poids de la dépense publique dans le PIB
qu'on connaissait en 2019 qu'est-ce que
ça fait rapidement sur avant de parler
de l'emploi bah ça vous fait un déficit
qui selon nous va se maintenir à 4,8
vous voyez sur les sur sur les sur 2023
2024 il y aura une légère baisse alors
là aussi je suis d'accord avec Patrick
mais à court terme ça n'empêche pas une
baisse de la dette parce que ce qui vous
a montré c'est avec l'inflation dans 10
ans d'accord mais quand vous regardez
l'inflation aujourd'hui oui benah ça
fait un petit effet sur la dette
publique d'accord et donc si la dette
publique baisse selon nous en 2023 c'est
parce que le le le le le l'inflation
enfin le taux d'intérêt réel là et
l'inflation aujourd'hui est pas à 2 et
demi l'inflation est bien plus élevée
donc ça a bien une incidence à très
court terme après je serai d'accord avec
son analyse sur le sur le moyen terme à
très court terme on peut avoir une
baisse de la dette publique liée au fait
que le G nominale la croissance plus
l'inflation est bien plus élevée que que
que le taux d'intérêt d'accord alors
ensuite rapidement ah oui c'est ok alors
donc un mot sur la productivité parce
que mais alors comment nous on explique
alors je suis d'accord avec tout ce qui
a été dit je le dis différemment c'est
que le 6 point dont Patrick parlait ça
vous fait en France 1,3 million de
salariés de trop d'accord qu'on arrive
pas à expliquer d'accord donc soit c'est
ça veut dire que les salariés
aujourd'hui est 6 % de moins productif
que celui de 2019 et là il faut bien
entendu baisser les salaires réels de 6
% soit peut-être que il y a d'autres
explications parmi les explications don
Patrick en a parlé bon ici il y a une
quantification c'estàd qu'il y a il y a
un autre effet par rapport à aux effets
de Patrick c'est que le salaire réel a
baissé c'estàd la
rémunération déflatée par les prix de
production est bien plus bas aujourd'hui
qu'avant la crise si on croit que le le
coût du travail est plus bas aujourd'hui
qui a un effet coût du
travail en nombre d'emplois bah ça vous
fait 130000 emplois de plus les effets
mentionnés par Patrick sur la durée du
travail ben nous on les value à 160000
c'est effectivement l'absentéisme
l'apprentissage ça vous fait 250000 mais
il y a un autre effet non mentionné
c'est toutes toutes les aides y compris
PGE d'accord ça a permis de sauver
beaucoup d'entreprises et ça a donné
aussi la liquidité à d'autres
entreprises donc en sauvant les
entreprises vous avez sauvé de l'emploi
et en donnant des PGE à des entreprises
qui en avaient pas besoin ça leur a
permis d'avoir des marges de manœuvre
également pour maintenir de de de
l'emploi nous on les value à quasiment
300000 donc ça veut dire que globalement
on explique 70 % deeffet fait il reste
quand même 480000 inexpliqué d'accord et
ce qui est intéressant dans les secteurs
c'est que ces facteurs là expliquent
l'intégralité de l'emploi dans les
services c'est qu'il y a pas de perte de
productivité inexpliquée d'accord c'est
l à ces phénomènes est-ce qu'ils sont
structurels ça on prend en discuter moi
je le pense pas mais c'est discutable en
revanche explique pas ce qui se passe
dans l'industrie dans la contion et donc
là il va falloir réfléchir mais je
pourrais vous dire si vous avez des
questions parce que il me manque du
temps mais voyez qu'en gros par rapport
à ce que disait Patrick effectivement on
retrouve bien les six points ce que on
indique ici nous dans nos prévisions bah
c'est qu'il y aura un léger rattrapage
mais quand vous mettez un peu de
productivité c'est là peut-être que
j'aurais un notre désaccord avec Patrick
ça veut pas dire que c'est trop
optimiste voyez même quand nous on met
un peu plus de productivité que que que
que ce que peut mettre le gouvernement
et donc je serai encore enfin patri va
dire qu'on est encore trop optimiste
mais voyez que on est très loin d'avoir
rattraper du retard donc il va bien
enfin nous on considère pas mais du coup
ça ça ça ça joue beaucoup sur ce qu'on
va dire sur le chômage parce que dans
nos prévisions bah on détruit des
emplois contrairement au gouvernement
d'accord et le chômage repart à la
hausse et donc voyez le problème de
pouvoir d'achat vous êtes en j'ai dit
que je faisais on faisait pas
d'austérité mais on arrête les aides au
moment où le marché du travail se
retourne d'après nous ah donc là il peut
y avoir des petites tensions sociales à
venir de ce point de vue bon désolé
d'avoir
dépassé temps bon merci madame merci
messieurs on va passer directement aux
questions on va on va on va se donner un
peu de temps parce qu'il faut engurger
tout
ça différ petites nuances d'approche et
cetera donc c'est toujours un peu
difficile donc c'est le rapporteur
général qui va d'abord peut-être vous
interroger
oui d'abord pour vous remercier de nous
avoir présenté vos analyses on va
essayer
de
de vous faire expliquer ou
l'inexplicable parce que c'est quand
même normalement on vient l'objet de
cette table rondes en vous invitant
c'est de de mieux comprendre et en fait
on repart
avec de nouvelles questions je dis pas
autant de questions mais de nouvelles ce
qui ce qui je vous dis ne me rassure pas
parce que sortant d'une campagne
électorale dans laquelle je le disais
encore tout à l'heure il y a un mot qui
est employé à tout bout Dechamp dans
tous les domaines c'est le mot
compliqué tout est devenu compliqué on
on m'a dit c'est c'est très compliqué
c'est hyper compliqué et ça rejoint
d'ailleurs le le un double facteur la
confiance en l'avenir et le moral des
troupes quand il y a un problème de
confiance en
l'avenir vous l'avez dit sur le taux
d'épargne il reste très élevé
donc néanmoins est-ce que vous vous êtes
en mesure de nous dire de votre point de
vue vous avez déjà donné des éléments de
réponse mais est-ce que vous pensez que
ça va être durable puisque dans les
raisons de ce taux d'épargne élevé vous
en avez évoqué certaines mais voilà il y
a aussi une incertitude or je pense
qu'on ne résoudra pas les difficultés
dans lesquelle la France se trouve si on
n'arrive pas à mobiliser l'épargne
sachant qu'elle est euh détenu par une
partie
seulement des Français et je ne suis pas
sûr et et aujourd'hui ceux qui
pourraient libérer cette épargne c'est
cell et ceux dont on
a besoin et qui pourrait d'ailleurs
ensuite deuxième question sur le la
question de l'emploi
ou alors si je je crois ou si j'écoute
de davantage ce que dit Patrick
Arthus ce serait d'améliorer la
productivité
mais mais est-ce qu'en améliorant la
productivité on le fait de quelle forme
est-ce que
c'est en amplifiant la
qualification générale d'ailleurs des
c'estd est-ce qu'on améliore aussi la
productivité ou le temps de travail des
des plus qualifiés voilà quel quelles
sont selon vous les orientations est-ce
que mettons en donnant une durée de
travail plus importante qu'elle soit
défiscalisé ou pas ça c'est peut-être
pas le premier sujet mais
au personne et à la main d'œuvre
qualifiée est-ce que ça profite plus à
la croissance je crois que c'est
important parce que il faut quand même
que on arrive à rétablir les finances
publiques qui me paraissent alors j'ai
j'ai pas tout à fait la la la même
analyse que vous madame duchen j'ai moi
j'ai pas bien vu pour tout vous dire
dans le budget dans les prévisions
budgétaires et dans la loi de
programmation qu'on vient d'étudier
euh j'ai pas bien vu les pistes
d'économie enfin c'est une voilà voilà
c'est une dégradation continue prévue je
dirais malheureusement
assumé ce qui veut dire est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est tenable avec un niveau
de croissance permettant de nourrir un
redressement de la situation économique
et de l'emploi ce qui me et je
terminerai par
là ce qui m'amène sur
finalement ce qui a permis de bâtir ces
scénarios pour le gouvernement donc
est-ce que c'est prévision de croissance
vous paraissent
crédiible est-ce qu'elles sont crédibles
à court et moyen terme à moyen terme
j'ai bien entendu que 25 27 j'entends
plus
d'Alert de risque de dégradation de
notre
situation je dirais économique
financière et budgétaire et dans ces
prévisions de croissance est-ce que
vous vous arrivez à identifier ce qui
relève plus de la consommation des
ménages dans la décomposition des
administrations publiques et puis de là
aussi de dans la part de
l'investissement ce qui relève entre les
entreprises administration publique et
parce que le gouvernement l'a mis
évidemment le commerce extérieur dont
j'ai alors je vous dis tout de suite
j'ai beaucoup de mal à croire qu' peut
être un facteur d'amélioration
vu la
dégradation et le niveau qui est le
nôtre depuis un certain nombre
d'années merci monsieur le rapporteur
général je propose que on prne
l'ensemble des questions vous répondrez
ensuite comme vous le savez pour ceux
qui viennent déjà depuis quelques fois
dans l'ordre inverse nous commencerons
par Monsieur
hier madame du alors ce point de méthode
éant étant donné Christine Lavarde puis
mar
CARG merci monsieur le Président donc je
vais vous poser une question que j'avais
adressée au président du ha conseil des
finances publiques qui m'a dit que
c'était pas dans C émission comme l'a
rappelé madame duchen à savoir faire un
contrefactuel de la prévision
macro-économique du gouvernement puisque
sur C en fait vous avez pris les
hypothèses un peu les unes derrière les
autres vous nous avez dit ce que ça
changerait en terme de dette de PIB de
croissance à horizon 2027 mais les
hypothèes elles sont pas toutes
indépendantes les unes des autres donc
il faut les croiser pour nous donner une
idée en fait de la
variation qui pourrait advenir en 2027
si effectivement on prenait telle ou
telle hypothèse donc est-ce que vous
avez fait ce travail et si oui est-ce
que vous pouvez nous nous donner les les
grandes conclusions et ma seconde
question serait sur selon vous chacun
avec votre votre prisme la meilleure
méthode pour pour aller chercher
l'épargne des ménages et l'injecter dans
l'économie puisqu'on voit bien que c'est
une pour moi c'est une des réponses en
fait à la déficience de la ressource
publique merci Christine mariecla CARG
puis merci monsieur le Président c'est
plusieurs petites questions demande de
précision qui s'adresse à à tout le
monde en
fait sur la sur la contrib tion
respective des problèmes d'offre et de
demande il me semble que que soit aux
États-Unis la zone euro c'est autour du
Tau d'utilisation capacité de production
tourne autour de 80 et que c'est plutôt
stagnant voir en en légère régression
est-ce que ça voudrait dire que il y a
pas qu'un problème d'offre ou bien que
l'offre peut-être particulièrement en
zone euro ne n'est pas adapté à
l'évolution de la demande je sais pas ce
point sur la la productivité vous avez
tous parlé de des effets volume et
structure de l'emploi cétait assez
étonné que personne ne parle des
technologies alors pour dire aussi que
lesffet peut-être est inexpliqué
mais je suis étonnée et étonner aussi
que ça se situe
uniquement apparemment dans dans
l'industrie enfin que le gros problème
soit dans
l'industrie un peu étonné aussi de la
valorisation que vous faites de de
l'apprentiss dans parce que on parle
vous parlez de productivité par tête du
coup et pas horaire en fait ou ENF ouais
parce que je trouve c'est beaucoup de s
enfin par rapport à l'augmentation de de
l'apprentissage et enfin toujours sur la
productivité dans dans la mesure où
avant 2019 on s'interrogait déjà sur
enfin il y avait beaucoup d'éléments
inexpliqués déjà avant 2019 est-ce que
cette proportion d'inexpliqué augmente
ou pas voilà
merci merci mariecla Éric boet puis
thier oui merci monsieur le Président
plusieurs points qui ont été évoqués par
nos invité alors il y a toujours des
oximor intéressants dans les
présentations le ralentissement accéléré
par voilà c'est assz drôle oui c'est
toujours très
intéressant il y a des graphiques mais
aussi des
mots il y a une question que je me pose
quand même il y a de de diapos qui sont
passé la première dit l'inflation BAE
progressivement et la suivante dit mais
les prix continuent d'augmenter bon il
faudrait m'expliquer un peu cette cette
apparence contradiction voilà j'ai loupé
quelque chose voilà et dans le les
causes de l'inflation évidemment on a
parlé de la guerre en Ukraine d'accord
le prix de l'énergie mais le FMI et même
la Banque centrale européenne il y a
quelques temps avait pointé dans l'une
des causes de l'inflation l'augmentation
des marges des entreprises que vous
faites pointer d'ailleurs dans votre
graphique je sais plus à quelle page le
rectangle rouge qui a augmenté donc ça
semble corroborer ce commentaire que le
FMI et la BC avait avaient commis
deuxème idée je vais parler profit quand
même je serai pas dans mon rôle de ce
côté vous parler de baisse de
productivité d'absentéisme alors je
pense qu'il conviendra on le constate
tous mais d'analyser les causes de cette
situation il y a il y a sans doute des
choses bon c'est pas le c'est pas
l'objet d'aujourd'hui mais le sens du
travail le rapport au travail à sans
doute évolué c'est incontestable mais du
côté des profits ça se passe pas mal
quand même en
2021 on parlait de profit record toute
la presse économique 160 milliards
d'euros je parle des groupes du CAC 40
en 2022 on était en légère BAE 152
milliards et je pense que 2023 ne
s'annonce pas mal non plus puisquentre
avril et juin 2023 notamment la France a
vu une augmentation de ses profils les
grands groupes de 13,3 % c'est
d'ailleurs un record européen donc
est-ce qu'il y a pas un élément aussi de
réflexion à voir de ce côtélà 3è point
France stratégie a publié une étude il y
a quelques jours c'est le comité
évaluation des réformes de la fiscalité
du capital vous l'avez sans doute vu et
qui nous dit quand même des éléments
d'analyse assez intéressants aucun effet
de l'ISF sur l'activité des ETI n'a pu
être identifié c'est quand même pas
unodin et ensuite un peu plus loin dans
la conclusion les travaux de recherche
n'ont pas détecté d'impact du pfu sur
l'investissement et les salaires dans
les entreprises les plus exposées au pfu
donc ces deux phrases m'ont beaucoup
interpellé est-ce que vous auriez un mot
à dire là-dessus trème point sur la tête
on a parlé de l'éparne des Français je
viens de regarder le l'étude qui a été
publiée par la Fédération bancaire
française en août 2023 qui annonce un
total d'épargne tout produit confondu de
5956 milliards d'euros c'est deux fois
le montant de la dette je dis ça au
passage voilà et dernière chose depuis
depuis quelques depuis quelques mois il
y a une nouvelle doxa économique qui
semble pointtere chez certains
économistes y compris libéraux par
rapport aux baisses d'impôts que ce
gouvernement s'acharne à diminuer c'est
c'est leur c'est leur Domme absolu et
certains commencent à dire est-ce que
c'est encore opportun est-ce que c'est
pertinent alors qu'on a une dette qui
gonfle on va emprunter 285 milliards
d'euros l'année prochaine est-ce qu'
aurait pas lieu de mettre un coup
d'arrêt à cette cette pratique de la
baisse systématique de l'impôt parce que
l'impôt ben c'est la société c'est la
République quoi voilà
merci merci éic Thierry ci merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président de de
deux petites question la la la première
elle concerne une donnée que vous nous
avez donné concernant le l'Allemagne euh
c'est vrai qu' on a tendance en France à
citer le modèle allemand et je constate
au regard de la présentation que que que
vous avez fait qui a pour l'année 2023
il y a une récession qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qui l'explique et la deuxième
question elle concerne l'inflation
euh aujourd'hui est-ce que vous avez
dans le l'ensemble j'ai pas entendu dans
dans l'ensemble des présentations est-ce
qu'on a des données euh sur le sur
l'influence que peut avoir l'inflation
notamment sur les niveaux de revenus
est-ce qu'elle se fait ressentir de
manière différenciée en fonction des
revenus est-ce que ça a des incidences
sur le pouvoir d'achat merci merci
kierry Arnaud Bazin puis
michelev merci monsieur le Président
premier première question autour de la
compétitivité on a bien compris les
effets mécaniques du retour à l'emploi
sur la dégradation de la compétitivité à
court et et à moyen terme et puis l'ffet
à négatif à moyen terme mais plus
positif à long terme de l'apprentissage
moi je voulais vous interroger sur la
composante éducation dans l'évolution de
la compétitivité c'est-à-dire que on
constate depuis bien des années une
dégradation des performances de
l'enseignement de base dans notre pays
avec une place en queue de classement de
tous les pays développés pour les
résultats au tests internationaux là
est-ce qu'on on sait est-ce qu'on a fait
des études universitaires ou
autres faire un un lien entre la qualité
de cet enseignement et puis ensuite les
les grandes tendances de la
compétitivité la productivité pardon ma
deuxième question c'était sur la
compétitivité très rapidement il y a des
mesures protectionnistes qui s'annoncent
notamment avec la la prise en compte du
cycle de vie global des produits y
compris leur transport depuis les pays
lointains où ils sont fabriqués qui qui
ont manifestement pour but de favoriser
notre notre industrie automobile par
rapport à celle des Chinois est-ce que
ces élémentslà peuvent avoir un impact
sur les prévisions que vous avez
faites merci Michel canvette pu CIV
vermeiller merci monsieur le Président
je remercie aussi les les intervenants
pour leurs analyses je voulais juste
dire que face àintervention de d'Éric
boet à l'instant le rapport sur la
fiscalité dit aussi que
les réformes de Macron sur l'ISF la flat
tax ont dynamisé les créations
d'entreprises c'est peut-être un effet
positif qui a permis d'avoir une
activité soutenue telle qu'on a pu
l'évoquer dans les tableaux qui nous ont
été présentés à l'instant
euh je voulais sur la mobilisation de
l'éparne moi aussi et d'ailleurs avec un
paradoxe puisqu'on a de plus en plus
d'éparne mais de plus en plus de nos
concitoyens qui nous disent qu'ils ont
des difficultés à joindre les debout et
donc on a peut-être un un un vrai
problème dans notre pays mais la
mobilisation d'épargne aujourd'hui est
importante et comment la mobiliser
effectivement et en particulier pour les
logement parce qu'on voit bien que là il
y a un vrai problème de réduction de la
production de logement alors ça coûte
très cher à l'État les différents
dispositifs de défiscalisation mais
est-ce que il y a pas un intérêt quand
même à relancer une réforme du logement
sous quelle forme justement pour
utiliser cette épargne que vous avez
évoqué tout à l'heure a été évoqué aussi
le fait qu'il n'y avait pas de de de
baisse de crédit à l'investissement
aujourd'hui c'est Madame duen qui a dit
ça tout à l'heure euh mon interrogation
c'était de savoir si les PGE n'allaient
pas handicaper un tout petit peu les
entreprises parce que c'est un
remboursement qui est à venir et dans le
ralentissement que l'on connaît
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il y a pas un
risque de de défaillance d'ailleurs
accrue sur les PGE de ce fait-l dans
différents propos aussi ont été évoqué
la baisse de l'endettement public moi
j'ai plutôt le sentiment que la
l'endettement public il augmente
considérablement c'est vrai qu' en
valeur absolue en valeur relative du pb
PIB sans doute pas mais en valeur
absolue euh il augmente considérablement
et et peut-être que nous pouvons avoir
des inquiétudes sur le fait qu'à
l'horizon 2027 le niveau des intérêts
payés par la France risque être élevé le
premier poste de dépenses de l'État et
donc poser de sérieux problèmes quant à
l'équilibre budgétaire nécessaire de nos
finances public et puis dernier point
dernière question c'est sur
l'absentéisme euh puisque a été évoqué
une hausse significative de
l'absentéisme est-ce que cela n'est pas
dû à une certaine optimisation des
droits par une frangeche de la
population merci euh merci Michel Sylvie
veramer merci monsieur le Président je
remercie également les intervenants j'ai
une question courte qui concerne le la
dette plus plus exactement le coût de
notre dette avec un niveau d'épargne
record et puis des perspectives que vous
présentez qui sont
plutôt moins pire qu'ailleurs est-ce
qu'on peut espérer que le niveau des
taux d'intérêt auquel la France pourra
imprunter serait plutôt favorable de
façon relative par rapport à d'autres
pays
merci merci Sylvie
euh moi j'en auraai 30 après vous
exposer bon c'est évident on a toujours
envie de rentrer dedans et de de se
penser soi-même un peu économiste à tort
euh mais simplement si je veux aller sur
une question moi j'essaie d'avoir une
question ouverte un peu sur les les les
réponses qu'on peut faire quoi quelles
sont les réponses de politique publique
par rapport au tableau que vous que que
que vous décrivez parce que ce tableau
on peut prendre l'exposé des uns ou des
autres on peut prendre tel tel point
plus ou moins marqué sont des
différences de niveau mais pas des
différences globales donc quelle
politique publique faudrait-il vraiment
mener lorsqu'on parle de de de gain de
productivité en réalité il y a plusieurs
facteurs quels sont d'après vous ce
qu'il faut mettre en premier et et si
vous étiez ministre de l'économie au
Dieu ne plaise euh est-ce qu quelle
serait la mesure finalement sur cette
question du gain de productivité que
vous mettriez en avant moi je suis
intéressé par ce point et puis j'ai une
deuxième question sur un sujet qui a
fait un peu polémique euh je crois
d'ailleurs que Monsieur Artus était un
peu à l'origine sur la question euh
finalement du niveau d'inflation euh que
la Banque centrale européenne devrait
viser av ce débat qui c'est un peu
éteint mais c'est l'occasion de le
rallumer une minute il' il m'a semblé
que le le le débat portait plus sur
finalement peut-être le faire mais
surtout pas le dire que que finalement
que sur l'objectif lui-même j'aimerais
vous entendre un petit peu sur en quoi
pour vous ce serait de nature si pas
d'améliorer un peu les choses ou euh
d'être un élément positif pour résoudre
le le le sujet voilà alors vous savez la
grosse difficulté
c'est vous
avez un grand maximum de de 10 minutes
pour répondre à tout ça alors ce qui
veut dire ce qui veut dire que vous
choisissez vos sujets d'une certaine
façon parce que je je sinon on refait le
monde quoi donc Éric et hier d'abord
peut-être avec un maximum donc de 10
minutes mais voà je vais essayer de
choisir mes questions en en connaissant
les préférences des autres et donc
laisser alors mais bon globalement non
donc je vais aller très vite donc à une
question qui éit peut-être à DESS à
Sandrine sur comment on fait un
contrefactuel je vais faire un peu de
publicité pour l'OFCE allez sur le site
de l'OFCE il y a ce qu'on appelle depth
watch c'est ouvert vous mettez vos
perspectives de croissance vos
perspectives d'inflation vos
perspectives de taux d'intérêt vous
mettez tout cela et vous faites votre
scénario et ça vous dit qu'est-ce que ça
fait sur les déficite sur la dette et
cetera donc allez-y c'est extrêmement
facile à utiliser si vous y arrivez pas
à appelez-moi et je vous guiderai Pouret
de bouclage et c'est les et les effets
de bouclage sont son sont là donc vous
pouvez faire vous-même votre propre
scénario d'accord ok donc alors ensuite
peut-être des questions alors y a
peutêre àusage alors mais inversé
c'està-dire c'est inversé c'est que
c'est vous mange vous mettez plein
d'hypothèse vous avez V scénario de
croissance là c'est vous qui mettez
votre scénario de croissance votre
scénario d'inflation et ça vous dit
qu'est-ce que ça fait sur votre dette
votre emploi votre chômage et et cetera
et à l'horizon en plus de 100 ans donc
et je pense que c'est important de voir
a il y a les effets des fois vous faites
beaucoup d'austérité ça fait rien à
court terme et il faut attendre à peu
près 10 15 ans pour voir un effet sur
les déficits et la dette mais avec le
coût sur le chômage tout de même au
cours de cette période
euh peut-être les éléments qui alors
lequels je vais choisir l'apprentissage
comment on valorise l'apprentissage et
et pourquoi il y a il y a peut-être si
peu C peut-être ça la question voyez là
c'est en gros globalement c'est pas
parce que vous créez un apprenti que
vous créez un emploi d'accord quand vous
créez un apprenti il est possible qu' a
un effet de substitution avec un autre
type d'emploi c'est pour ça que
globalement on a que 250000 effets de
l'apprentissage il y a bien des effets
substitution et et donc c'est ces
éléments sont sont bien pris en compte
comment on explique
l'inexpliqué par définition on
l'explique pas dans l'industrie mais on
a des pistes c'est et ça répondra aussi
un peu à la question de de de d'un d'un
sénateur sur on voit pas les effets dans
dans dans certaines politiques notamment
la transformation l'ISF il faut quand
même savoir que c'est pas parce qu'on
voit pas d'effet de certaines politiques
que il n'existe pas c'est peut-être
qu'on sait pas bien les mesurer il y a
peut-être un billet aussi dans la façon
de faire et donc voyez typiquement
l'inexpliqué pour nous en terme de
productivité c'est quand on discute avec
les leschef d'entreprise ben c'est c'est
lié à une sorte de rétention de main
d'œuvre dans certains secteurs
industriel notamment dans l'énergie
notamment dans l'aéronautique où il y
avait des carnets de commande plein mais
il manquait l'approvisionnement donc la
valeur ajoutée s'est effondrée ils n'ont
pas licencié pour autant parce que ça
devient une denrée rare ils maintiennent
cet emploi d'accord donc on n pas de de
données pour le chiffrer d'accord mais
on considère là que tout ça ça c'est la
rétention qui ne peut pas durer
longtemps et que globalement c'est ça
qui va faire les gain c'est de la
réserve de productivité donc qui
aujourd'hui dans certains secteurs la
main d'œuvre c'est une dré rare d'accord
et on préfère la garder même si elle
nous coûte cher al ça ça peut ça peut
faire qu'à court terme hein ça peut pas
être advitable mais c'est comme ça qu'on
explique euh ces éléments dans
l'industrie et dans la construction euh
inflation prix voyez c'est vraiment deux
éléments différents l'inflation c'est la
vitesse des prix c'est-à-dire que vous
voyez quand vous roulez euh à à 100 km/h
vous avancez d'accord si demain vous
roulez à 50 et que ensuite vous roule à
50 km/h vous allez continuer à avancer
donc il peut y avoir et pourtant vous VZ
dire vous avez ralenti et ben c'est la
même chose l'inflation baisse c'estàd
que votre vitesse passe de 100 à 50
d'accord mais vous continuez à avancer
et donc du coup globalement les prix
continuent à progresser ça je pense que
c'est extrêmement important donc de
faire bien la distinction entre
l'inflation et les prix il peut y avoir
une baisse de l'inflation mais les prix
qui continuent à augmenter quelle est la
meilleure et vous me dites dès que je
suis à mes 10 minutes hein je m'arrête
immédiatement j'ai déjà dépassé
sur la meilleure utilisation de
l'épargne moi il me semble
qu'aujourd'hui voilà est-ce qu'il faut à
tout prix que cette épargne retourne
dans la consommation non c'est pas
obligatoire cette épargne une épargne ça
sert à quelque chose alors aujourd'hui
quand ça reste sur les comptes en banque
bon on peut peut-être être déçu de
l'utilisation que vont faire les banques
de cette de cette Man et peut-être qu'il
faudrait effectivement le guider vers
autre chose vers un financement
d'entreprise ou pourquoi pas des
finances publiques encore une fois voyez
ce que ce qu'ador les Français
aujourd'hui en terme d'épargne c'est
d'aller acheter de l'assurance vie en
euros parce que c'est sans risque mais
l'assurance vie en euros c'est quand
même de la dette publique en grande
majorité donc en gros les ménages ont de
l'épargne donc si je refais le la
séquence c'est que il y a eu un quoi
qu'il en coûte qu'il fallait faire mais
sans doute un peu trop généralisé c'est
allé aussi sur les ménages qui n'en
avaient pas besoin et on les a empêché
de consommer cette cette somme et donc
c'est c'est de l'épargne très bien c'est
ces ménages là préfère potentiellement
les mettre en assurance vie bon ben ça
veut dire que quelque part l'état
récupère avec des intérêts c'est ça le
problème d'accord mais cette C après
c'est que va faire l'état d'accord de
cette Man et c'est la bonne utilisation
donc du coup de de la dépense publique
qui est en cause mais pas forcément
est-ce que il faut à tout prix flécher
l'épargne vers tel ou tel type de de de
secteur voyez vous faites pas boire un
anâne qui n'a pas soif si on n' pas
envie de prendre des risques si on veut
continuer à prêter à l'état bah
continuons prêter à l'état mais c'est du
coup la responsabilité du coup de l'État
à bien utiliser cette
man du coup je vais peut-être répondre
juste à qu'est-ce qu'il qu'est-ce qu'il
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait faire en terme
de politique publique moi je pense mais
ça a été dit c'est pour ça que je je je
je dis maintenant je pense
queaujourd'hui sur la productivité vous
avez compris mon propos je ne crois pas
alors peut-être c'est une différence
avec Patrick que les les on est le le le
salarié aujourd'hui soit 6 % moins
productif que le salarié 2019 je
n'arrive pas encore à être persuadé de
ce de cela c'est possible mais je suis
pas encore persuadé de cela et il y a ce
travail qui nous dit non il y a d'autres
choses qui permettrai d'expliquer
pourquoi donc j'en suis pas certain et
donc je suis pas sûr que ça soit au
gouvernement à essayer à tout prix
d'accord et d'ailleurs sa politique
c'est d'essayer d'enrichir la croissance
en emploi donc au contraire de faire
baisser la productivité pour essayer de
continuer à faire baisser le chômage moi
je pense que la question aujourd'hui
c'est plutôt comment se fait-il qu'il
ait
alors qu'il y a on embauche à tour de à
tour de bras encore des difficultés de
recrutement et là je pense que le
logement effectivement la bonne façon de
répondre à ces besoins là et la
politique du logement est à mon sens la
grande absente d'accord de de la
politique du gouvernement vous vous vous
vous arrivez à résoudre le problème du
logement vous arrivez à résoudre voyz il
y a des études passionnantes entre le M
logement et l'échec scolaire des enfants
donc ça répond à l'éducation le Mall
logement et l'absentéisme
le mal des parents le M logement et la
mauvaise intégration sur le marché du
travail donc vous répondez au
mallogement vous répondez au problème
d'éducation en partie vous répondez au
problème de l'absentéisme alors
attention au mot absentéisme ça veut
dire que ça serait volontaire c'est
peut-être que de l'absence parce que on
est malade he il est possible qu'on soit
réellement malade aussi hein donc je
préfère utiliser le mot absence t que
j'ai pas la preuve que c'est
l'absentéisme et et et ensuite voyez les
problèmes de difficultés de recrutement
peuvent aussi être au fait qu'il y a un
problème de mobilité et le logement est
source de de voyez avec les prix du
logement aujourd'hui vous ne bougez plus
de votre logement et donc il y a un
problème de mobilité donc oui la
politique du logement est sans doute la
meilleure politique aujourd'hui pour
résoudre un un un nombre croissant de de
problématique et donc ça je pense que
moi si j'étais en tout cas au
gouvernement je mettrais l'accent sur
cette politique du
logement merci Monsieur hier Mons
oui je vais pas répéter ce que ce dit
donc sur la productivité il y avait une
question sur le en fait sur
l'intelligence artificielle qu'est-ce
qu'on attend de l'intelligence
artificielle sur la productivité alors
on dispose d'études
locales c'est-à-dire
qui ces études montre que les
entreprises et ça concerne beaucoup plus
les services que l'industrie qui
implante de l'intelligence
artificiel réduisent l'emploi peu
qualifié et crée un peu d'emploi très
mais réduisent l'emploi il font plus de
gain de productivité simplement c'est
des études locales on avait les mêmes
sur Internet et quand on a bouclé les
effets d'internet on s'est aperçu que
internet aussi ça créait par exemple
beaucoup d'emplois peu qualifiés sur les
plateformes Internet et donc on ne sait
pas encore je crois qu' il faut avourer
notre ignorance sur l'effet final à
moyen terme de de le de l'intelligence
artificielle sur la productivité mais
quand vous regardez localement une
entreprise ça fait des GS de
productivité clairement
euh sur le taux d'épargne alors il y a
tout tout le monde sait que le taux
d'épargne est croissant du revenu hein
si le le le le le le les 20 % de la
population au revenu le plus faible ont
un taux d'épargne de 2 % les 20 % au
revenu le plus fort ont un taux d'éparne
de 28 %. donc c'est c'est c'est très
inégalement distribué ce qu'on sait pas
d'habitude en que ce ce qui est un peu
étonnant pour un économiste plus
étonnant
c'est que les les les les personnes
âgées épargnent plus que les jeunes le
le taux d'épargne il est maximal chez
les plus de 70 ans alors qui normalement
devrait des épargnés et en plus les plus
de 70 ans prennent plus de risque avec
leur épargne que les plus jeunes donc ce
n'est absolument pas vrai que il faut
assurer les personnes âgées contre les
risques financiers ils prennent beaucoup
plus naturellement de risque financiers
parce que ils n'ont plus de risque de
revenu hein c'est c'est l'explication
théorique qui quand vous avez quand vous
avez touché votre retraite vous avez
plus de ris de revenu pouvez plus pouvez
plus devenir chôur et donc vous prenez
plus de risque financier donc le
vieillissement de la population va faire
monter le taux d'épargne et va accroître
l'pne à l'épargne à risque et ça je
pense que c'est une bonne nouvelle parce
que dans les discussions sur l'épargne
il faut absolument arrêter vu le
contexte de de penser que il faut il
faut transformer l'épargne en
consommation il va falloir qu'on épargne
davantage parce que on a un déficit
extérieur qui est de à peu près de
points de PIB et les rapports divers sur
la transition énergétique la
biodiversité l'eau et cetera nous montre
qu'il manque manque tro à quatre points
d'épargne pour investir suffisamment
dans tous ces domaines donc si on on
n'épargne pas plus on finira avec 5 ou 6
points de PIP de déficit extérieur et on
le pays fera faite donc on aura besoin
de transformer de la consommation en en
épargne et donc d'inciter les ménages à
plus épargner et arrêter les subventions
à la consommation alors c'est pas très
sympa euh mais mais c'est l'économie de
reconstruction quoi on doit transformer
le capital brun au capital vert et il y
a pas d'autre choix que d'épargner plus
pour arriver à faire les investissements
nécessaires donc voilà et puis par
ailleurs il y a pas d'épargne non
utilisé je er a dit les Français
éparnent 18,2 % je crois dans le dernier
chiffre de leur revenus cette épargne
finance les entreprises l'état voyez il
y a pas il y a pas d'épargne qui soit
qui soit non utilisé
euh le le le logement euh y a il y a un
vrai problème moi je suis d'accord avec
er je je vais je vais répéter
mais il y a des
statistiques qui viennent de des agences
immobilières qui viennent des rage
d'entreprise qui qui montrent que un
recrutement sur deux échoue parce que le
la personne ne peut pas déménager elle
est bloquée dans son dans son logement
actuel et donc il il y a vraiment il y a
vraiment la politique du logement c'est
extrêmement important simplement comment
on fait je veux dire on on a des prix de
l'immobilier qui sont 40 % plus élevés
en France qu'en Allemagne et et la la
raison c'est probablement que
l'immobilier enfin les et en plus les
ménages allemands sont locataires tant
qu'ils sont tant qu'ils sont actifs ils
achètent un ement pour leur retraite
mais il louent un logement pendant
qu'ils sont ils sont en activité et les
logements en Allemagne appartiennent aux
assureurs donc probablement il y a
beaucoup moins spéculation immobilière
en Allemagne ce qui explique
probablement le niveau des prix beaucoup
plus bas en Allemagne que qu'en
France
la l'objectif d'inflation bon alors j'ai
j'ai essayé de pousser cette idée auprès
de quelques gouverneurs de banque
centrale et ils m'ont dit jamais nous ne
changerons l'objectif d'inflation et
CETA il va y avoir un problème parce que
la BCE a perdu une partie de sa
crédibilité donc on sait comme
économiste que l'inflation va retourner
au niveau de l'inflation anticipée à
long terme si l'inflation anticipée 2,7
% l'inflation retournera pendant au bout
de quelques années à 2,7 % mais pas à 2
%. et puis on a plein d'idées pour
expliquer qu'on aura une inflation
supérieure les coûts de la transition
énergétique les obstacles au commerce
mondial on en a pas beaucoup parlé mais
Sandrine en a parlé le le le FMI recence
2500 obstacles au commerce mondial alors
qu'il en recensait 300 il y a 10 ans
donc donc on on a on freine le commerce
mondial donc c'est
inflationniste la tension sur le marché
du travail hein le le recul de la
population active et donc on on aura
plus d'inflation donc moi ma prévision
d'inflation à moyen terme c'est
peut-être un peu autour de 3 % si la BCE
persiste à avoir un objectif d'inflation
de 2 % on aura des taux d'intérêt réels
extrêmement élevés et 1 % ça sera pas la
limite des taux réels on va aux
États-Unis on est déjà à 2,2 et on aura
on aura 2 2 et demi de taux d'intérêt
réel et donc les taux d'intérêts
nominaux vont continuer à monter et ça
et ça c'est une très mauvaise nouvelle
et une une remarque additionnelle
l'investissement immobilier les achats
de logement dépendent des taux d'intérêt
nominaux à long terme parce que vous
avez des contraintes de de revenus vous
pouvez pas vous endetter et payer des
intérêts supérieurs à 30 ou 35 % de
votre revenu donc c'est une contrainte
de revenus courant et ça cré une
dépendance de des achats d'immobiliers
au taux d'intérêt nominaux à long terme
et pas au taux d'intérêt réel à long
terme donc donc ça ça c'est c'est
vraiment le le le la perspective de
d'avoir des des taux d'intérêt réel à
long terme plus élevé qu'aujourd'hui
c'est c'est une perspective extrêmement
désagréable et puis dernier point
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire bon je je
crois que bon il
faut il y a le problème de l'éducation
vous
on l' tous mentionné enfin si le la la
la réforme 1 c'est la réforme de
l'éducation qui est la seule et de la
formation professionnelle qui est la
seule à même de faire repartir la
productivité moi je je je crois pas que
la productivité repartira spontanément
là je dis ferdériic parce que la
productivité en France elle décline
depuis 2018 2018 et 2019 c'était deux
très bonnes années du point de vue de la
conjoncture il y avait pas de de de
d'entreprise qui retenaient des emplois
et cetera il y a et et la productivité
descend et descend beaucoup en 2019 donc
donc je crois que c'est autre chose
c'est c'est les attitudes vis-à-vis de
l'emploi c'est la composition de de
l'emploi avec beaucoup plus d'emploi non
qualifiés que d'emplois qualifiés et ca
et et donc et donc j'ai un peu de mal
avec les hypothèses de redressement de
la productivité et donc il faut faire
des politiques d'éducation vous savez de
formation vous savez que formation
professionnel il y a moins de 20 % des
Français les moins qualifiés qui ont une
formation professionnelle dans leur vie
he c'est vraiment absolument effrayant
quoi euh il faut il faut réformer quand
même France travail parce que France
travail reste une une institution qui
s'occupe davantage de l'indemnisation
que de la formation vous savez qu'un
personne qui tombe au chômage en France
reçoit une formation professionnelle en
moyenne au bout de 6 mois de chômage au
Danemark c'est au bout de 3 jours donc
il y a quand même des progrès à faire
euh il faut et puis il faut investir
davantage en nouvelle technologie et en
recherche développement on on a un
niveau d'investissement en nouvelle
technologie en recherche développement
qui est plus bas que la moyenne de la
zone eururo et deux fois plus bas que
que les États-Unis donc donc il y a il y
a vraiment un problème de et puis on
peut bien prouveren comparant les pays
que si on fait davantage
d'investissement en technologie et
davantage de RD on a des gains de
productivité plus rapides donc je crois
que je crois que c'est c'est mon
programme ça serait réforme d'éducation
réforme for formation professionnelle
visant plutôt les PE qualifiés que comme
aujourd'hui les personnes qualifié des
grandes entreprises
et grand grande politique de
redressement de l'investissement en
technologie et de la re développement
merci beaucoup de vous plier cet
exercice de la proposition s vous vos
propositions je va revenir sur quelques
points
d'abord vous m'avez posé la question de
savoir si le
la la trajectoire était
crédible de de croissance etette
finances publiques moi je dirais qu'elle
est peu peu prudente euh elle est peu
prudente parce que on l'a vu sur la
repose sur des hypothèse de croissance
on a détaillé tout ça mais je pense
surtout qu'elle factorise assez mal les
incertitudes aujourd'hui et que en
général les économistes d'ailleurs les
factorisent assez mal euh les
incertitudes géopolitiques les
incertitude financière et on sait que ça
pour le coup on a on le sait les
périodes de durcissement des politiques
monétaires ont pour conséquence en
général des périodes d'instabilité
financière on en a vu déjà des
manifestations aux États-Unis avec la
faillite de quelques banques américaines
donc c'est c'est ce facteur là voilà il
n'est pas compris dans les prévisions
des des 4 ans à venir et je pense qu'il
y aurait intérêt à euh faire preuve de
d'une certaine prudence dans dans les
dans les prévisions et se donner
justement des marches ça veut pas dire
se mettre dans des dans des corners ou
des trajectoires impossibles mais voilà
c'est à mon avis une attitude qu'il
faudrait
promouvoir sur le sur la trajectoire
également peu prudent et peut-être peu
documenté aussi c'està-dire vous l'avez
très bien on a dit la la même chose hein
je je n'ai pas dit que les économies
étaient documentées elle ne le sont pas
donc elles sont ambitieuses et il va
falloir que dans les années à venir
effectivement C ces économies soient
réaliser documenter ce n'est pas
facile une revue de dépenses qui est en
train de de d'être implémenté
d'expérience pour l'avoir vécu je sais à
quel point c'est un travail ingras
difficile donc ça c'est pour le pour le
la partie trajectoire et stratégie de
finances publiqu
euh ensuite j'ai j'ai quelques remarques
qui vont faire écho à ce que disent mes
collègues je vais le je vais le dire
avec mes mots euh je commence sur
l'investissement hein vous vous posez la
question qui à mon avis très juste de la
la dynamique de l'investissement dans
les mois qui viennent sur le court terme
je pense effectivement qu'on est à un
tournant sur les défaillances
d'entreprisees euh on commence à le voir
hein nous dans nos dans nos bilans
bancaires on commence à voir des
secteurs où les entreprises qui ont
beaucoup recouru au PGE commencent à
être en difficulté hein il y a un
certain nombre de de secteurs de
services notamment où on voit les
difficultés les
tensions des secteurs aussi et ça fait
peut-être écho au débat sur la fiscalité
où il y a eu beaucoup de création
d'entreprises sur les années récentes
mais des entreprises qui ont pas été
forcément qui qui n'avaient pas
forcément la surface financière pour
tenir au covid donc on est en train de
voir tout ça et on voit aussi auss le
mur d'échéance non non seulement sur les
PGE mais sur les échéances URSAF vous
devez tout savoir dans vos dans vos
relations des difficultés qui vous sont
remontées ça c'est très c'est très clair
on entre dans un changement le retrait
des aides publiques est en train de
provoquer quelque chose dans le tissu
productif et peut-être qu'aussi provoque
des réajustement par rapport à un tissu
qui était pas
forcément en lien avec la demande Pr je
prends un exemple il y a eu beaucoup de
création d'agence immobilièr avec le
l'alimentation de des des des de la je
sais pas si on peut employer le terme de
bulle mais en tout cas de
l'expansion immobilière en France depuis
quelques années bon bah là en ce moment
c'est en train de se retourner donc
vision sur l'investissement vision
sectorielle il va se passer des choses
sur le tissu productif et pas seulement
dans l'industrie on le voit beaucoup
dans les dans les
services ça ça m'envoie sur
l'investissement à plus long terme moi
je souscris vraiment enfin ce que dit
Patrick sur la politique monétaire et
pour le formuser avec mes mots le 2 %
d'inflation je ve dire quel degré de
répression financière on est en train de
s'imposer pour rejoindre la cible
d'inflation c'est ça le débat est-ce que
est-ce que vraiment il faut en passer
par ce cheminlà et ça c'est un débat de
politique
économique voilà c'est c'est c'est là
qui est le sujet entre entre 3 %
d'inflation et 2 % combien d'entreprises
vont aller au
tapis pour rétablir la cible
d'inflation sur
l'épargne même avis que vous il y a
effectivement on a été un peu collé au
court terme quand on a parlé de
mobilisation de l'épargne et de de de de
que le fait que les ménages puissent
puiser dans leur épargne pour alimenter
la consommation à court terme c'est un
débat en soi c'est-à-dire que quand on
regarde la le le le surplom d'épargne
covid
euh mais je pense que les les ménages
les plus contraints financièrement et
les plus en difficulté non on peu de
marge hein pour puiser dans les leur
épargne pourer consommer or c'est ce ces
personnesl en général qui font le voilà
qui alimentent la reprise de la
consommation ce qu'on appelle les
ménages contraints donc peut-être qu'il
est pas étonnant qu'on garde ce surplom
d'épargne tout simplement parce que
c'est pas les ménages qui qui doivent
consommer qui le peuvent donc on va
peut-être garder ce surplom d'épargne
encore un certain temps et et vraiment
je souscris à ce qui a été dit on voit
sur dans les comptes bancaires on voit
les on voit rien baisser le surplomb
d'parne reste et on voit des
recomposition entre les comptes courant
les comptes à terme l'assurance vie tout
ça circule mais il y a pas de
dépargn donc le sujet aussi c'est
pourquoi faire et vraiment je suis tout
à fait d'accord avec ce qui a été dit
sur bah les besoins on va avoir besoin
de cette épargne pour financer la
transition
écologique parce que le risque de
transition c'est c'est plus un risque
économique c'est c'est un risque presque
existentiel maintenant donc quand vous
parlez de contrefactuel faut quand même
commencer à s'inscrire dans des
trajectoires où on commence à parler de
carbone aussi même à court terme les
banques sont en train de le faire et
donc pour financer la transition
il va falloir aussi se le dire il faut
prendre du risque alors Patrick tu dis
que les les plus âgés sont prêts à en
prendre tant mieux parce
que la transition ce sont des
investissements c'est du remplacement de
capital brun par du capital vert mais
c'est aussi un Paris sur des
technologies qui n'existent pas encore
et donc il va falloir
investir et prendre du risque donc donc
je pense que ce surplom d'épargne il
faut le voir aussi comme une opportunit
unité pour faire tout ce qu'on a à faire
en complément de ce que pourra faire la
sphère publique et les finances
publiques pour aller orienter
correctement les investissements
apporter des
garanties plutôt que des subventions là
où c'est possible voilà il y a toute une
réflexion sur la la mobilisation globale
des finances publiques et privées sur
ces sujets là et je termine puisque vous
vous me demandez m mes solutions c'est
bien voilà question compliquée mais sur
le potentiel
il y a un point qui qu'on n pas relevé
tous les trois sur le le potentiel de
croissance affiché par le gouvernement
dans les dans les trajectoires de moyen
terme il y a un élément fort c'est
l'emploi l'emploi potentiel et et le
fait que dans les les années à venir on
va allonger la durée de vie au travail
avec
l'allongement de avec le le recul de
l'âge de la retraite qui a des éléments
d'offre aussi sur la mobilisation
de de l'emploi par la réforme de
l'assurance chômage on est d'accord ou
pas mais il y a ces éléments là ces
ingrédients là il figurent dans la
trajectoire de finances publi et il
relèvent le potentiel d'offre dans un
horizon de moyen terme donc ça c'est un
choix aussi
historique relativement consensuel je
dirais en France d'aller mobiliser les
ressources en main d'œuvre et
d'augmenter le taux d'emploi des jeunes
actifs des seniors notamment et des
femmes le deuxième élément sur la
productivité et le potentiel c'est il y
a aussi un choix historique et là je
commencais à bosser il y a il y a un peu
plus de 30 ans mais il y a un choix
historique sur les sur l'emploi et le
coût du travail qui a consisté quand
même à à
réintégrer dans l'emploi les
travailleurs peu qualifiés par le biais
des allègements de charge euh au prix
d'une certaine baisse de la productivité
apparente du travail et ça c'est aussi
un choix historique assumé je pense par
qui est assez transpartisan aujourd'hui
et donc ce choix-là bah moi je pense
qu'il faut l'assumer encore parce qu'on
n pas encore au bout de l'histoire on a
encore un chômage structurel qui est
quand même très élevé hein par rapport à
d'autres d'autres pays donc voilà moi ce
ce ce ce voilà cette histoire làà je la
assume et je pense qu'il faut que voilà
qu'elle se prolonge et en complément de
ça il y a il y a tout ce que ce que ce
que vous avez dit aussi qui est il faut
faire des efforts sur la formation La
formation tout au long de la vie la
formation continue la formation initiale
et ça ben voilà c'est aussi une histoire
sans doute sur lequel on a du retard et
où il falloir accélérer dans les années
qui viennent voilà et puis sur
la transition et potentielle le les
investissement de transition je ne suis
pas sûr que ce soit des investissements
de productivité et ça il va falloir
l'assumer
aussi parce que c'est un risque contre
un autre VO merci monsieur le Président
bien merci beaucoup madame merci
messieurs de vous être rendu disponible
pour cette
audition qui comme vous le savez est à
la fois suivi évidemment par les membres
de la commission que vous avez là mais
également très suivi sur Internet parce
que ces sujets-là aujourd'hui
intéressent évidemment beaucoup de nos
concitoyens merci encore d'être venu et
bonne fin de journée bon
appétit